we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
caller who apparently believes that me
interviewing them is so important that I
may end up judged by God on Judgment Day
negatively if I don't interview them
take a listen to this you will be held
accountable for every soul that has
missed the Word of God because you
didn't have me on your show you
understand that you will be held
accountable on Judgment Day yeah very
scary very very scary threat and I guess
that's something we should look into
because the apocalypse can be pretty bad
I've heard about people being raptured
and it's both painful and embarrassing
we've got a great bonus show for you
today there has been a helicopter crash
in New York City and this actually
relates to something I've been thinking
of for a long time which is just more
generally the the risk that aviation
over the New York skyline represents and
when I lived in New York I thought about
this a lot including with the landing
pattern of for LaGuardia Airport we'll
talk about that on the bonus show and
get into detail about it also the
governor of Alabama has signed into law
a chemical castration bill which I want
to discuss with you and California will
become the first state to extend health
benefits to some people some people who
are in the United States illegally three
really important stories plus some more
behind-the-scenes stuff that's going on
on the show and lots of other
interesting things get the bonus show
there's two ways to do it at least two
that I can think of offhand become a
member at WWN pakman.com coupon code
this is 20 20 saves you 40% you still
get all the benefits including the
world-famous daily bonus show on which
we regularly hear from producer Pat
become a patron at the $5 a month or
greater level patreon.com slash david
pakman show another way to get instant
access to the David Pakman show bonus
show
and we will speak to you then and
otherwise you'll have to wait until
tomorrow where there will be a really
great show including the return of
hatred mail and much much more that's it
for today